hey welcome to new project camp update
so we bought a big piece of land on our
prototyping a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous update you could
see that we set up
two shipping containers with a workspace
and a kitchen and we tried to get them
here to set up base camp and we're still
waiting for them to arrive
but we also need a place for people to
sleep so in this update we're gonna set
up
we call it the van area so clearer space
where people can park their van and
tends to sleep
and we also have a big update which is
we got an address
so the place where we're gonna park the
vans is still quite rough
it's gonna be right here in this area
with all these chopped down trees
and you might remember this from update
one where we discovered this
well okay i just saw that i
wasn't aware of this but this whole area
is kind of chopped down
and apparently i just have a call that
it's
someone in the neighborhood they sort of
had an agreement they could chop
this bushes so here we have a lot of
chopped down trees kind of rough can't
really do anything with it because it's
all covered
in the trees but we kind of want to use
this area to put some vans
if people drop by for visiting so we're
going to clean up
all the little branches and trees to
make sure
we can actually drive here and it's also
nice that it's a bit covered with the
base cam there
so you can sort of sleep a bit in this
bushy area
so yeah time to clean up
[Applause]
[Applause]
and this might not look like an exciting
task but it's kind of nice to do
actually it feels like we're cleaning up
a very messy area
stick by stick cleaning up all the stuff
that's laying around
or cleaning well i guess it's more just
putting stuff on a big pile
getting there already looks a bit
cleaner big pile of
trees big pile just this area needs a
bit more cleaning
so now we have a lot of roots sticking
out which is
not ideal the best way would be to dig
them out so they also don't grow back
and your soil
is homogeneous however
that it's a lot of work to take them out
their roots everywhere
and uh we don't really have a machine i
guess how it would usually be done
so for now i'm just gonna chop them all
very short with the chainsaw
and then we can just keep walking and
driving on top and hopefully that will
be enough to
make this flat area
[Music]
so now we're going to make fire with
some chocolate paper i don't know where
this comes from probably mattia hita
eating this chocolate
i really don't know it's you wasn't it
so
wait a minute
so
and finally we needed to level the soil
a bit to make it less bumpy
and clean up all the little sticks that
were laying around
i also actually discovered this big hole
in the ground no idea where it came from
or what it's for but
yeah it's there so we continue to clean
up
until our good old friend dropped by
there's the rain again
all right so here we have the van area
cleaned up and we can use it to park the
vans and it's a pretty big area so we
can also really drive around here
and i guess around eight vans could be
parked in this area
and it's right next to the base camp and
the main reason for that is that we want
to keep our infrastructure in the
beginning very much together
on one central point in the land and not
all over the place
so we expand from that single point
so you can now sleep in the van area and
the base camp is one step
closer of getting ready for people to
come and help not yet though
soon so the other day i noticed i
broke my light here
but i didn't really know how it happened
until i was looking back
the footage from the drone and i
realized that uh
yep right there broke the light
but another way more important update
this week is that we could actually pick
up
our address we got one and an address is
not just for receiving post but it
unlocks many other things like with an
address you can sign up for official
services like a bank account
or in our case very important to ask
quotations for connecting electricity
so an address is kind of a big step
right
so we are just in front of the post
office
right now and this should be the moment
where we just get our
address so we can start getting posts
finally at the land let's see
so the moment took quite a while over
three months of waiting and many phone
calls
and today is finally the day exciting
so what was the news news is that we
have more phone calls to do
so
no others maybe later yes
okay yeah so we didn't get the address
that day but a few days later we
actually did get it
so now we have an address i could
finally get my portuguese bank account
took just one hour to not even fill
again just waiting
and a lot of paperwork let me count
one two
three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
31.
37 pieces of paper together
and that's why they grow a lot of
ecolyptus in portugal
now we know but yeah and address also
means we can receive
meal so we went on the hunt for a
mailbox
and we found an old lady that sells them
and mailboxes are quite a thing around
here
they have many variations and they even
have one for
breath so a person comes to your home to
deliver
not post but breath that's cool so we
bought one and took the baby home
and we're gonna put it right there
why why do we put it there uh
we put it there because we have a very
bumpy road
uh so we have to put it
way before the land so that the
levers can be made and of all places
around here
why do we put it there
because it's the
i don't know i don't know either we just
put it there
[Music]
look at this beautiful thing that's
ceramic numbers
a metal inlet a sloppy lion face
yeah it already gathers quite some
attention
all right so that was this update video
we now have a big pile of wood
and i think in next week we're gonna try
to see if we can
chop it down with a wood chopper from
someone uh there we actually have flakes
to put on the soil and we got rid of our
wood
but yeah if you want to see how that's
going to go make sure to subscribe if
you want to see all the other updates
make sure to check out this playlist
and if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
to see how you can help us out thanks
for watching see you in the next update